Brian's with us in Sioux Falls South
Dakota hi Brian what's up well hi Dave
thank you for taking my call
yeah I tell you I'm a little nervous
about the but you and I'm about ready to
receive I'm 44 years old I've been
married three times
I started accruing debt when I was you
know 20 years old
my first thing I got was a $300 credit
limit city bank card
oh and my bride-to-be and I were
pregnant we tried to start a business
but a hyper cleaning service and you
know we use the credit card that's
that's now or is that 20 years ago
well that's 20 years ago where are we
now well um now I am $300,000 in debt
I'm a least um I got a $200,000 judgment
what's the turn ourselves our judgment
from the business contacted it no an
accident with no insurance car accident
and so that was probably 98 so that's
always hung in there I got judgments for
everything I mean I owe everybody money
but I've never had a mortgage and I've
never had a car well and so you have
$300,000 in debt but 200,000 of it's a
judgment lien what's the rest of it yeah
well like I broke my arm up in the late
90s and it was a severe break no health
insurance no nothing there you know that
was 50 for me all 35 $40,000 you know I
had a you know just medical bills I've
never have never been able to hear these
people chasing you actively well I mean
I get bills every day I mean is there
anybody like sewing you right now or uh
not currently somebody there's a old
bill collector that just attached onto
my check for my wages so they get from
from medical bill um well yeah they they
end up getting like five or six local
businesses or
you know uh in the area you know where
there be a check check okay so you might
$27 what was what is your best year you
ever made income was uh that probably
looked at in thirty eight thousand and
that was a man when I was married my
second wife
Lisa fifteen years ago I'm currently
married now so you know I said you said
you were going to but chewing why what
what have you done to get about chewing
okay I mean I'm I've always been
I've always been in about the same
income bracket you know just just barely
over starving you know always know I'm I
mean what does that mean you should get
your budget that's just sounds like
you've been struggling okay well I mean
you know life life has always been a big
struggle and you know to get by on more
income I've always a beg borrow or steal
or not literally steals you know just
kid cry just been scratching and clawing
trying to eat right right so you know
now I'm currently you know I saw what
you're telling me is is that you're
persistent income problem has had you
without health insurance without car
insurance which have been disastrous
decisions yeah and you're persistent
income problem has made you unable to
address these judgments because you
never have any money except barely keep
the lights on and food right yeah we
don't you know we we're just over the
income limits for food stamps and so
really all there than anything what we
have is a career crisis yeah yeah and we
got to start thinking about okay Brian
is 40 so what is Brian going to do when
Brian is 50 years old that's going to be
making more money than ever made in his
life well and what steps are we going to
take to get to that I don't know what
that is yeah yeah earlier the only thing
that's consistent in your discussion
with me is the lower income problem and
and that has to do with absolutely no
plan and you just got stuck in a job and
never had a better plan to do something
else never never took a class or
anything else and I would really sit
down and start setting some detail goals
and say alright I've always wanted to be
a and you fill in that blank and I think
I have the talent the skills the
brainpower to do
that now what have I got to do and it
may be it may take you three years it
may take you five years to work towards
that in an apprenticeship or to take a
couple of classes or to get a
certification in a certain field but uh
and and I'm not saying just go after
money but I can tell you if you do not
have a detailed plan that you're aiming
at and a step-by-step breakdown of baby
steps of how you're going to get to that
you're going to wake up at 54 and still
be making twenty seven thousand and
there's no sin making twenty seven
thousand that make you a bad person it's
just made your life hell it's just
because you don't I mean you don't have
the basic health insurance you don't
have the basic car insurance those
things are on top of you so you get
these things over the top of you I mean
what happened if you got into something
and you started making seventy five to
eighty thousand dollars a year someday
maybe it took you five years of work and
to get working extra jobs to get there
but maybe you got there in five years I
mean how much would your life be changed
it would be completely transformed and
so I would really say that you need to
start thinking about what you want to be
in the next phase of your life and then
do the research the study of what it
takes to be one of those talk to people
that are one of those and how do I get
my income to do that again we're not
just chasing money usually you're going
to find the most money around something
you like and that you're good at and you
have a natural bent for I want to send
you a book called start Kelly is going
to pick up in our pickup as our phone
screener and get your address and I'm
going to send you a copy of the book
start as my gift this is the Dave Ramsey
show
you
you